okay beautiful [ __ ] to push
psychobabble and we got location with
healthier eye
this isn't exactly a text based game but
it's like a detective
look your files game and I love files
I just love Faust oh my god 1994 great
year for files right here oh my god
I'm computer mug hold this or head space
to inspect the text no thank you
let's see here what else we got here
though toaster picture who is she who is
she the key right there and I got that
now so okay let's check out this poster
right alright cuz you can't take out the
wall can't can't do that huh
yeah get out here alarm clock any Keys
anything you know there's a lot of [ __ ]
here lockbox
he locked the vision ah more Case Files
I will check this in a bit hello's trash
just get you know to take that why
anything on here safe we don't know the
combination
let's scroll that anything up here well
what the [ __ ] is that a board are a PD
database code decryption key letters on
the 26 numbers so it's here 8 times 2 is
16 H goes to P
okay egos 2p as well what the [ __ ]
no get out of here what's this
Brooklyn BC our powernow now yeah okay
yeah these cables okay I guess this is
jump into this right what is it Glen
dark ink don't mind if I do
okay come on all right anything over a
single been scheduled passwords too late
oh you [ __ ] to 13 hg t WN okay hg t w IM
marine boys or in [ __ ] now okay one sec
I think we need a file yeah
case report okay Jack did unix quickly
found dead his face was unexplainably
completely missing what da [ __ ] ages
picture of them many are scared to do
explanations case and that one -
superstition make sure it doesn't go
public
okay alright the second one sick ones in
here I think great yeah okay
okay similar to bridges as victims had
dad without inherit cause right missing
her right eye and left eyebrows times a
distress there's a right handed
aggression her face
they're all lodged within her face her
fingers right there we will prove to be
possible really strange annotation if
he/she could without I don't layer of
skin the [ __ ] not isolated incident a
photo is available in the database under
here at this down here see lowercase W
capital X 2/3 the standard decryption
method should work now pictured right
okay
see W of x-23 be the [ __ ]
oops
scheduled passwords
I have to take this disc at vocation in
graphics I need that
okay I guess what's good third one holy
[ __ ]
disgusting okay down the floor missing
eyes and mouth in the areas with
standish unharmed human flesh how is
that possible all dark bartender -
didn't want to move the real picture
attachment back over and there's a lot
of strains and please dots looking back
over them oh okay
so here the dots we got no just kidding
five eight eight one three look at this
report left I don't ever hear that's an
eye one three two okay
you are dots I'm sure so spirally can't
do this right on three two that's the
max okay Flav on ya
standard decryption should work example
boy okay
codes must be presented under the guise
as the standard unchanged code okay so
that C thing has to be translated
decrypted the following with it
we should have my pointer okay
for close to 11 said +5 no wait
+7 7 so okay so all the numbers need 7
add it to it H is 1 2 3 4 5 6 3 7 8 he
goes to oh what the [ __ ]
hey I'm Zack has aged gonna pee
I don't envy
so she's double it so V is 25 24 23 22
220 240 [ __ ] that it's [ __ ] hard
[Music]
fucking-a okay let's see some [ __ ]
rafter this would be 4 minus 26 18 1 2 3
a 5 24 23 22 to the 120 okay so this
makes a lot of sense now
yeah okay get a [ __ ] pencil Kenny
so I'm going to do some changes around
here huh huh ideas no bad
we'll see if I can add a source we had a
window capture
I see this no bad okay so I hope you all
people could see this [ __ ] it's
beautiful it's beautiful
now our code was C W X - 3 D so C is 3
ABC so it's gonna be 6 here the sixth
one is f just goes to capital f W is 25
24 23 so it's gonna be 23 times 2 is 46
and 46 minus 26 it's 20
so that's 26 25 24 23 22 120 that's T
lowercase D X so fine in a second I
think all the numbers we just add seven
and 3 plus 7 is 10 bees to cause the 4
which is lowercase D Oh guys let's talk
about X is X is 25 24 24 times 24 wait
24 times 2 minus 26 22 which is 25 like
25 24 23 22 V capital D okay yeah we got
this we got this so far
just [ __ ] minimize this I can't we'll
keep this and where should we keep this
let's keep his over here hey okay so I
think we have to go back to the code
database right FTP 911
it's the [ __ ] code you piece of [ __ ]
you piece of [ __ ]
okay so what if you double it now
numbers work they just straight up add
no you're not adding 7 because 6 is plus
7 doesn't you're adding a teach at no
doublet add 1
wait
at seven at eight at nine okay let's see
here let's go back a little bit let's go
back a little bit for ads 7 so 3 at 6
and 2 adds 5 okay so 7 and then 3 that's
sick which is 9 okay all right I think
we cracked the case boys be away dad at
boys well 10 years alone
the [ __ ] where's the rest okay yeah same
how do you have it on home skin right
there okay well I think it's behind me
at least
[ __ ] up into power sir sir
that's a [ __ ] okay what do you poor p.m.
the [ __ ] is that can I help you sir yeah
don't touch my bed [ __ ] ask us tick
I think he liked that
huh they got me they take the eyes
ending be the [ __ ] I guess we'll never
know the rest of the endings if you want
to actually see the other endings I
guess you could just like look at a good
YouTube channel cuz this one's over like
this game is over like do you know that
else here for you like see you later
kids